merci alexandre tout à l'heure nous
partons à présent à la découverte de la
région qui nous accueillent aujourd'hui
l'alsace première étape avec nos
correspondants régionaux
jérôme soûlard et patrice your maker qui
nous amène à ungersheim certaines
communes ne se trouve un musée vivant
tout à fait extraordinaire visite
c'est un beau voyage au coeur du terroir
alsacien village traditionnel où les
paysans travaillent encore à l'ancienne
des variétés de blé d'orge d'avoine
aujourd'hui presque introuvable
ungersheim
c'est aussi un village plein d'histoire
celle de ses 70 bâtiments maisons syrie
ou chapelles démonté puis remonté pièce
par pièce poutre barres poutre à
l'écomusée d'alsace le sauvetage du
patrimoine est un défi quotidien depuis
20 ans c'est pas un vrai village dans la
mesure où ici contrairement aux vrais
villages les gens peuvent rentrer dans
les maisons nos visiteurs là peut voir
un tas de choses qui ne voient pas
ailleurs et c'est ça l'intérêt
d'écomusée au delà que d'être un endroit
très agréable à visiter dans lequel on
apprend un tas de choses ça sert aussi
de clé d'entrée pour comprendre un petit
peu l'architecturé le mode de vie de la
région
ungersheim
c'est vrai c'est avant tout un musée
bien vivant avec des ateliers
interactifs et des animations
mon avis que ça te rappelle
mais donc les mains et le bout de bois
qui en dessous
des questions difficiles pour ces
visiteurs d'un jour mais dans la chaleur
du foyer on apprend ici concrètement le
secret des gestes d'antan transmis par
jean-luc le forgeron faire comme ça ça
me mène du temple énormément de
visiteurs passent repasse y en a qui
reviennent avec eux j 1 on a un
sentiment un partage même s'ils sont pas
de mon côté de l'en clean on se partage
la joie le plaisir du travail qui a été
fait non loin de la forge
roger lui aussi a pris cette passion du
bel ouvrage tranquille dans sa forêt il
surveille la délicate cuisson de son
charbon de bois à l'ancienne travail
exigeant bien sûr travail de patience et
à foyer central qu'il faut alimenter en
gros pendant cinq six jours j'aurai nuit
au début toutes les deux heures après 3h
4h 5h 6h dernier charbonnier français en
activité à ungersheim roger est
également animateur toujours disponibles
pour les visiteurs
ils vont vous réponds niveaux expliqué
sont pas verts de renseignement quoi
savait que visiter musées plus on voit
quelle sauce une bouche pauvre mme assez
pauvre du charbonnier à la cour de ferme
le décor ici est plus vrai que nature
dans ce musée village se cachent deux
siècles de patrimoine alsacien
c'est aujourd'hui le plus grand écomusée
du territoire national